[Music]
joining me today is a truth seeker a
self experimenter of brain food expert
and author of the upcoming book genius
foods max Luger beer welcome back thanks
so much for having to the Rubin report
this is a back although most of my
audience now will not know you from the
Rubin report but you used to do the old
Rubin report seems like a real lifetime
ago doesn't it yeah yeah back back in
the day when it was a panel show it was
a panel show years ago on T uit I don't
even know what we were doing I have
almost no recollection of my life at
that time it's you know the every time
that I was on it though I would always
have such a good time and I always would
think to myself like how good you are at
what you do and so I'm just so honored
to like be here in this new set and to
see your success like you know the fact
that you've just blown up it's awesome
cool well thank you and I feel the same
and I'm glad that our our pads have sort
of you know I've been on parallel tracks
kind of growing together you have a new
book coming out which we're gonna talk
about shortly the last time I saw you
though it was about two or
two-and-a-half years ago you had me eat
some really nasty stuff on camera that
you felt I don't even know why you had
me eat it but you wanted me to what did
we eat you know because you're doing a
lot about food yeah so you're you're
testing this stuff out we ate natto
which is a fermented soy bean dish that
is very commonly consumed in Japan and
that was my first time ever trying it
because I think yeah back where your old
set was we were like a few blocks away
from like a Japanese market yeah yeah
and I was like wow what a great place to
go and try to find this food that I've
heard so much about because of its
purported health benefits but I'd never
tasted it and it's known for being
particularly gnarly like it smells like
dirty socks yeah and I knew that you
were back at the studio and I was like
what you know there's no better time to
try this gnarly food than with my friend
dave rubin so i brought it back and we
tried it and yeah i don't think you were
that into it it was pretty nasty yeah I
mean I'm a pretty open eater and we're
gonna get a lot into the different types
of things that you should be eating and
fermented food obviously good but it was
kind of like
beans in this gooey sticky sauce and it
stunk to high hell it's got the clothes
you're saying it was good for my brain
it's very good it's very good yeah
there's I mean you know it's the top
known source of vitamin k2 which is a
really important vitamin for vitamin for
maintaining calcium homeostasis in the
body basically keeping calcium in the
parts of your body where calcium should
be yeah like your bones in your teeth
and out of your soft tissues like your
kidneys and your arteries and stuff like
that there's really good research on
vitamin k2 and yeah I just you know
natto is one of these foods they eat it
in you know one of the world's Blue
Zones
so I just figured why not give it a try
I would say it has the consistency of
like baked beans with a little bit of
like personal lubricant that's world
together yeah it is obviously not
appealing it's that sounds quite
horrific that should've had something
here for you to taste on camera don't
even awesome by kicking the ball back
yeah it's something like that all right
maybe maybe next time all right so first
I thought well we start off with before
we get to the book is I think sort of
what you're doing is interesting because
it kind of parallels what I'm doing here
where we're watching mainstream media
crumble and people are coming to people
like me perhaps and and Shapiro and Joe
Rogan and all these alternate voices to
hear about news and I also think that's
happening in the food world and the diet
world as well where you used to maybe
watch the nightly news to find out what
you're supposed to eat what the latest
fad is what all's you're not supposed to
have it cetera et cetera and now people
are going to people like Joe Rogan who I
just mentioned Tim Ferriss people like
you did you sort of see that thing
coming and that's why you started
getting into this world and we'll talk a
little bit about your the personal
reasons why you got into just a sec yeah
no yeah I mean it's it's an amazing
point I feel that you know look we live
in a time you know and in a world where
we have all of the world's information
at our fingertips at any given time with
our smartphones you know and research is
out there information wants to be free
so you know whereas prior generations I
feel like you know could have could have
only received health information from
the doctor or nutrition information from
the nutritionist today you know I think
things are different where people that
are passionate and that do their
homework in a way I'm not just talking
about going to you know media for
their health information but you know
PubMed is something that anybody can
search it's how you know the research is
out there not everybody's gonna be
qualified to the degree that they can
you know understand for example medical
literature or even cut through the
jargon but there's a lot that people can
glean from what is readily available I
mean one of the ways that I try to tell
people to become educated about health
and science and research is to look at
websites that put out university press
releases that often accompany studies
like Science Daily for example or
medical Xpress you know oftentimes when
a study is released the University will
write a press release that basically has
the gist of what the study basically
found in layman's terms and that's often
what journalists will use to write
pieces for like the Huffington Post or
Fast Company so what I tell people is to
do is cut out the middleman go to the
press releases read them then go to the
research article compare what you read
in layman's terms in the press release
to the research article and that can
actually help you interpret research so
the average person though obviously
you're not going to do all that legwork
and I think that's where someone like
you comes in going I will sit down read
all this stuff yeah and now distill it
to you in a way that makes some sense
yeah well my background I mean you know
before before really diving into health
and nutrition and fitness I was a
journalist you know at Current TV which
was my first job out of college and so
getting to work with the journalists
there you know Peabody award-winning
journalists award-winning storytellers
it gave me a sense of how to ask
questions how to pick my sources and
then when I became interested in
nutrition and health you know I kind of
knew not only where to look but how to
look and and yeah and you know my unique
job gave me the time and the ability and
you know my personal circumstances yeah
and so yeah I don't expect everybody to
do their own research but I do think
that people should do their own research
I do think that the the you know health
care health care is something that we
like to pretend that we're able to sort
of offload to our health care providers
right but you don't go to a doctor to be
healthy you go to a doctor to become
free of disease or to have a disease
treated I think health care really is
something that
you know starts in the kitchen and in
the gym and it's something that we you
know that we have to in you know and
view our lives with day to day yeah and
I wanted to start with that because I
think it sets the table properly because
I know on YouTube there's a million
people talking about health and diets
and all that stuff and I want people to
understand that you're somebody that I
know has been in this for a long time
actually doing the research so let's go
to that that personal circumstance part
that you mentioned you sort of got into
this it's probably only about five years
ago you with the circumstances with your
mom and all yeah I'm taking yeah so when
I left Current TV to sort of figure out
where I was gonna go with my career it
was sort of in that downtime in between
jobs that my mom started displaying very
strange symptoms that I couldn't explain
I mean memory you know problems with her
memory she complained of brain fog and
she also had changes to her gait that
were very apparent I mean my mom is a
spirited New Yorker and New Yorkers walk
very fast they walk everywhere and my
mom ran a business so cognitively she
was always very sharp and essentially
what we what we saw is that my mom's
cognition took like a it just seemed to
have like you know like a web browser
with too many open tabs is how I
described it you know just you know like
a stuttering framerate on a youtube
video with a poor internet connection
and my mom's gait changed where you know
before she was a very fast Walker
she almost developed sort of like a
shuffle and both of these strange
symptoms seemed to come on at once and I
had no prior family history of any
neurodegenerative disease you know
dementia to me was not a term that I was
familiar with I didn't know what
Alzheimer's disease was actually when I
thought about the word dementia you know
I thought about the character from The
Addams Family movie you know like it was
like cousin it's sore Fester's like a
crush or something her name was dementia
which was actually pretty funny but yeah
so coinciding with like my ignorance I
had the time to go with my mom to some
of the top neurology departments in the
country we're very fortunate to be able
to do that we went to you know NYU
Columbia and New York
Johns Hopkins in Baltimore the Cleveland
Clinic all in hopes of trying to find
some kind of diagnosis for my mom
what was going on and it was in 2011 at
the Cleveland Clinic where my mom was
diagnosed with a neurodegenerative
disease for the first time and she was
prescribed drugs for both Parkinson's
disease and Alzheimer's disease and at
that moment I mean my world pretty much
stopped like I it was I'm a pretty chill
guy that that weekend or that week in
Cleveland it was the first time in my
life that I'd ever had a panic attack I
was just so freaked out by the
possibility that my mom had this fatal
disease for which there is no cure or
particularly meaningful treatment and I
basically became unable to think about
anything else
let alone my career I ended up you know
my mom started taking the drugs I ended
up coming back to LA to try to you know
look for jobs and do what it is that you
do when you live in LA and you're a
journalist on TV and I basically became
unable to think about anything other
than nutrition you know every waking
minute that I wasn't you know doing
something career related I was in PubMed
digging through the research and what I
think really motivated this journey for
me was the fact that what I uncovered in
the research was a stark contrast to the
you know what neuroscientist Norman
Doidge calls neurological nihilism to
the to the despair and bleakness that I
experienced in those doctors offices
with my mom yeah can you describe what
that is yeah what are they actually
telling you well the despair yeah so I
call it diagnosed and audio's you know
basically there's a there's a there's a
quote that I learned that is circulated
amongst medical school medical school
students that neurologists don't treat
disease they admire it that's because
the brain is a mystery for the most part
I mean we know quite a bit about the
brain which is surprising but there's a
lot more unknowns than notes at this
point and treatments for neurological
diseases are very limited you know no
there's no approved drug for Alzheimer's
disease that has a disease modifying
treatment they only act as band-aids
like chemical band-aids essentially that
work to sort of artificially boost
neurotransmitters in the brain but they
do nothing to solve the underlying
Pathology and you know drug trials are
notoriously bad Faiz are just announced
for example that they're gonna stop
pursuing pharmaceutical treatments for
Alzheimer's disease because treating the
quest to find a drug to treat the
disease has like a ninety nine point six
two percent fail rate that's worse than
any other you know disease so meaning
that they're getting out of the game
altogether they view this as something
that can't be solved yeah via drugs I
mean that sounds incredible I don't know
how often that happens with other
diseases right that sounds that sounds
pretty staggering yeah I mean another
huge pharmaceutical company basically
recently announced this ain't the same
thing axe event yeah it's a massive fail
right so think about it from like the
perspective perspective of an investor
you know are you gonna invest in an
Alzheimer's or in any drug trial that
has you know a ninety nine point six
percent fail rate it's you know it's
just not a smart investment and that's
why Alzheimer's disease research is
criminally underfunded or I shouldn't
say criminally it makes sense although
it's tragic because you know if there
was a pill tomorrow that I could give my
mom that would help in a meaningful way
of course I wouldn't want it and I
wanted for all the five million people
in America that are suffering from an
Alzheimer's disease well I just think
you know because I can bring almost
anything back to politics it's like this
is a good argument for a publicly funded
scientific research because it doesn't
have to deal with the bottom line where
you're saying yeah these companies they
have to deal with the bottom line and
shareholders and they have to then stop
at some point if they can't get far
enough where something publicly funded
they can keep going to the science
hopefully although you found that there
are some other ways to deal with through
this and that's that's really what
changed your life yeah so I you know I
so on the one hand I became really
interested in learning about diet you
know potential diet and lifestyle
interventions that I could throw my
mom's way to sort of help her but then
at the same time I became really
conscious of my own brain health because
I learned that changes begin in the
brain decades before the first symptom
of Alzheimer's disease which is just one
form of dementia but even Parkinson's
disease by the time you show your first
symptom of Parkinson's disease half of
the neurons involved in movement
in that part in the part of the brain
associated with Parkinson's disease are
already dead so these are not you know
like any chronic disease these are not
diseases that develop overnight they
take years if not decades to develop and
I became really interested in doing what
I could do in my own life to maximize my
brain health so that I might not have to
deal with what it is that my mom is
dealing with yeah so we'll go from there
and we'll slightly shift to your book
and obviously this is all intertwined
this is the advanced copy the book comes
out in a couple weeks and I was reading
a little bit and I just thought that the
opening alone was was really perfect so
I'm just gonna read the the opening
paragraph unless do you want to read it
in your own voice maybe maybe you should
you know what okay I'm gonna let you
read the writing paragraph of your book
oh man I thought it was pretty beautiful
thank you so much nestled within your
skull mere inches from your eyes are 86
billion of the most efficient
transistors in the known universe this
neural network is you running the
operating system we know is life and no
computer yet conceived comes close to
it's awesome capabilities forged over
millions and millions of years of life
on earth your brain is capable of
storing nearly eight thousand iPhones
worth of information everything you are
do love feel care for longed for and
aspire to is enabled by an incredibly
complex invisible symphony of
neurological processes elegant seamless
and blisteringly fast when scientists
tried to simulate just one second of a
human brain's abilities
it took supercomputers 40 minutes to do
so so yeah I mean the brain isn't we
each are heir to this amazing birthright
yeah I know forged over millions of
million you know millions millions of
years of life on earth and yet the
modern world is fighting it at every
turn you know from the toxic industrial
products that have saturated the food
supply to the dietary advice that we've
been given for decades to now the fact
of the pendulum sort of swing in the
other direction and people are it's sort
of like a dietary free-for-all you know
yeah so alright let's shift okay my
dietary yes so I want to talk about your
or a second so you know that at the
moment I'm in the middle of this sort of
slow carb
died at this high fat no sugar no car
yes diet i've actually in about as of
this taping in about nine days i've lost
about three pounds it i actually feel
pretty good I have these like brief
moments where I want to punch random
people I think I'm being a little meaner
on Twitter that I don't know whether it
would be for real I mean like there is
just like a little bit of mood stuff but
my energy feels pretty good I'm not
getting that sort of crash from coffee
that you might get it like two o'clock
but then has people drinking all kinds
of chemicals that after their 2:30
feeling or whatever that is right so I
basically feel pretty good it's pretty
much just meat and fishing and veggies
and a lot of butter and you said you
said to me right before we started maybe
but maybe the butter isn't the great
grass-fed butter
yeah well grass-fed butter is definitely
good you know I mean there's definitely
trace nutrients in it vitamin k2 which
we talked about earlier CLA which is
being studied as a potential cancer
fighter and fat burner but it's a you
know one of the hallmarks of a healthy
food is nutrient density when you take
any concentrated fat you know butter oil
they're not very nutrient dense they've
got a lot of calories 9 calories per
gram a tablespoon of oil has 140
calories and and yeah and it's just it's
a lot of calories with very little
nutrients and there's you know on butter
alone there is not a lot of evidence to
say that butter improves fat burning or
brain health or anything like that so
you know I like to tell people that you
know consuming fat the the high fat low
carb diet if you already have fat all
you need is a low carb you know your
body has the fat to burn right so this
body's gonna go to your fat probably in
your stomach area yeah as opposed to
what a lot of people are doing with
these diets is you're loading up on fat
to sort of get the burn going on fat and
then the hope is that then it yeah you
see your family your buddies gonna want
to burn the fat that you're consuming
before it burns the fat that you have
around your waist and the point of a
diet like this I would assume is to lose
some of the fat around your around your
waist yeah I mean that's why I think
this conversation is so interesting
because I you know Ferriss Tim Ferriss
is the one that sort of did the slow
carb thing for the 4-hour body whatever
it is and it's like well alright he's
focusing on that part the weight-loss
part so I am seeing some results on that
yeah you're focusing on the brain part
which is also very important to me you
know idiot I'm someone that likes to
know what I'm talking about to be able
to have clean thoughts and all that of
course I like to I mean I like to focus
on the whate part too I mean that's a
you know it's a concern for I think
everybody and it's a good way also to
just have this conversation about
nutrition and healthy eating you know
when you start a low carb diet gonna
lose a lot of water weight at first
because what you're doing is you're
depleting the amount of glycogen stored
in your muscles glycogen is basically
how your muscles and liver stores sugar
but for every gram of glycogen that your
muscles store you also store about 3 to
4 grams of water so that's why once you
start depleting the glycogen from your
muscles with vigorous exercise or just
by not eating a lot of carbs you lose a
lot of water weight very quickly and
that's also why when people stop you
know eating low carb and go back to
eating a higher carb diet their waitress
shoots up because their muscles end up
storing all that glycogen along with all
that you know with 4 parts water for
every one gram one part of of sugar
stored I think what we're gonna have to
do is like in a month from now if I can
keep running with this thing I'll have
to have you and Ferris on together you
guys got like poked me you can poke my
brain area you can poke my stomach will
figure out sounds great what happened
here alright so enough about my my diet
people I guess we'll see the result
right here on the YouTube okay so you
you start realizing that the the
medicine for dementia Alzheimer's these
cognitive degenerative diseases is not
quite there you start changing your own
diet but then also realize well this is
how I can also sort of help my mom and
help other people like this so what are
some of the first things that you
realized that we as people of generally
are doing wrong yeah well definitely you
know my diet used to be dictated by you
know what sort of conventional wisdom
was surrounding a healthy diet so I used
to build my you know base my diet around
grains I used to basically shaun white
carbs you know white rice white bread as
if it were some kind of toxin but if you
put a huge bowl of brown rice and in
front of me I would go to town on it
often asking for seconds you know every
meal had to include a grain and I would
notice that my energy levels throughout
the day always felt like a roller
coaster you know I couldn't really go
many hours after waking without eating
something right away and in between
lunch and dinner I was off I would often
find myself starving
and you know when I started looking into
the research I realized that there's
really no good evidence to say that
grains improve health I mean certainly
if you're metabolically healthy you can
tolerate grains which is not the case
for 50% of the people living in America
that are either either pre-diabetic or
diabetic and have essentially become
glucose or carbohydrate intolerant if
you're healthy though you can eat you
know rice and you could certainly
incorporate it as a means of an you know
improving athletic performance but that
was like really the first thing that I
did you know because my diet was never
very high and added sugars I started
cutting out the breads and the Rice's
and all that stuff and the pastas and I
noticed that my energy levels just you
know not only did they go through the
roof but they were more stable
throughout the day and you know without
even really trying my body composition
changed I started you know losing fat
which is something that was just like a
side bonus and again you know the
recommendations to eat grains because
many people do consider them healthy you
know how could quinoa brown rice bean is
about healthy come from misguided you
know nutrition policy over the past 50
years that have really been attributed
to the Mediterranean dietary pattern
that's this nebulous idea of how people
in the Mediterranean eat because
epidemiological research observational
population-based research shows that
they have reduced rates of
cardiovascular disease and neurological
disease but when you look at randomized
control trials which are the kinds of
trials required to prove cause and
effect
there's no good evidence to say that
grains improve health in fact when you
look at research control trials with
people with pre-diabetes or type 2
diabetes or obesity low-carb diets
seemed to win most of the time when
compared to standard low fat you know
conventional with conventional dietary
wisdom yeah so let's back up for a
second because you said something really
interesting that just sort of rolled off
your tongue it seems pretty freakin
goering and scary 50% of Americans are
either pre-diabetic or diabetic yeah
that's what the latest statistics so
what is actually what is pre-diabetic
so when you're pre-diabetic your your
blood sugar is higher than it should be
that's what a doctor will measure and
they'll say you should probably you know
change up your diet because you are at
risk for becoming a type-2 diabetic it's
sort of like this middle ground where
yeah your blood sugar is higher than it
should be do they know how much that
number has changed over the years I
suspect since probably the 50s when we
started all this processed food and
sugars and all that stuff that that and
soft turning scenarios that must have
tremendously increase that number yeah I
mean it's it's skyrocketed in tandem
with you know the obesity rates in this
country 60s two-thirds of people are
either overweight or obese and they've
kind of you know risen in tandem with
one another and the only thing that can
really explain it is the environment you
know because our genes certainly haven't
changed over the past 100 years as a as
a population so what has well the food
supply and you know there's a lot of
zealotry in the world of nutrition it's
a very you know people tend to feel very
religious about their nutritious
beliefs but you know in general what I
think most people would agree on is that
there's become a ubiquity of hyper
processed foods that are rich in both
readily easily digestible carbohydrates
pulverized grains stripped of their
nutrients and added fats and you know
both of these foods put together
basically create a stereotypical junk
food and that's really what most people
are consuming these days I mean 60% of
calories that Americans consume come
from these exact kinds of foods
ultra-processed foods I always think of
that commercial I don't know if they're
still running it but it's with Larry the
Cable Guy for prilosec otc
yeah and you know he's out there eating
the hotdogs and all this stuff and he's
basically like you can eat whatever you
want as long as I have your prilosec otc
I just turn it like it's like the pill
is the answer you know he's a pretty
heavy guy in the first place I have no
problem with him yeah but it's like that
that we go to do whatever the hell you
want and then here's our magic pill for
it probably not the best way to be
dealing with them no not the best way at
all I mean and the thing is you know
once you've won
the main drivers of of type 2 diabetes
and insulin resistance which category
which is one of us sort of which is the
hallmark of type 2 diabetes is
chronically elevated levels of insulin
which could precede a diagnosis of even
pre-diabetes by a decade so I mean
people are walking around eating on
average 300 grams of carbohydrates per
day exactly from the kinds of foods that
we're talking about hyper processed
foods and it's just doing a number on
our metabolisms our waist lines and you
know ingenious foods we explore you know
what it's doing to our brains and our
mental function and our moods yeah all
right so that's really where I want to
focus on this because I think that's
your expertise and I just find that
fascinating cuz I think there's a lot of
things happening right now that might be
changing some of our brain chemistry and
how we think and and all that sort of
stuff yeah so at any point when this was
happening with your mom did any doctor
say maybe she should change her diet no
that really not once yeah and again I've
been to all that the most storied you
know us news and you know whatever that
the annual you know ranking of hospitals
in America is and we were we went to the
top ossicles it's try to find a
diagnosis and not once was diet
mentioned at all and you know there's
there's not conclusive evidence on how
diet can affect somebody who has the
disease although it's starting to bubble
up in the in the literature but yeah I
mean you know exercise wasn't really
mentioned even though exercise is one of
the best ways to treat you know one of
the actually the the right the the
guidelines for treating mild cognitive
impairment were literally just updated
two weeks ago to you know to include
exercise as a means of treatment for
people with mild cognitive impairment
which is sort of like pre dementia which
often converts to you know diseases like
Alzheimer's disease but yeah so I became
I became fixated on on these sort of
alternate approaches to treatment and
even possibly prevention when I went
when I had that experience with my mom
because I've always been a big believer
in the power of diet and lifestyle just
seen it play out in my own life I mean I
go to the gym and I'm a different person
walking out of the gym and
walking into the gym yeah I mean
whatever cobwebs I have in my head are
gone you know excised like the demons
you know are excised with a good workout
and yet you know that's not something
that I feel like is common wisdom so
when this all happens to my mom I
started you know researching and I
realized that there's a lot of you know
insight out there both in terms of risk
factors for developing dementia you know
for example take the Mediterranean
dietary pattern which we talked about
before which is associated with reduced
risks of many chronic diseases yeah can
you explain to people what that is I
mean yesica lis a lot a lot of oils yeah
so it's like characterized by being
really high in extra-virgin olive oil
you know a glass of wine per day for
women wants to for men and then the way
that it's typically defined in the
medical literature is as being a it's
it's defined as being a grain based diet
and it all stems back from you know this
one epidemiologist named Ancel Keys who
basically in the 1950s stationed himself
on the island of Crete to look at how
that population basically ate and went
about their lives in the midst of a
major epidemic of heart disease in the
United States he wanted to see you know
what they were doing differently in the
Mediterranean region of the world that
we might be able to glean some
nutritional insight but the problem is
he and this is a story that's been told
by you know other people there's a
there's a great book called the big fat
surprise with you know the journalist
who wrote it really goes into depth on
this story but I talked about it as well
ingenious foods you know he was
stationed on the island during Lent so
it was a particularly lean time just
after world war ii and his observation
of their dietary pattern was one where
you know it was it was predominantly
grain based but people in the
mediterranean region they loved fatty
cuts of meat you know i have friends who
are born there and who visit you know
very frequently and they eat very fatty
cuts of you know meat lamb for example
yeah that's all but ignored in the
medical textbook definition of the
mediterranean diet and also when you're
observing a population as well as what
it is that that they're eating it's
impossible to ascribe causality to any
dietary element because what you're
observing is basically your
doing just that you're observing
variables but without doing a randomized
control trial it's impossible to prove
which aspects of that diet are causally
related to the you know the phenotypes
the outcomes that you're seeing in terms
of the population health right so so
that and that could partly also just
because of geography and lifestyle
whether the amount they move around yeah
if it's cold you might need a little
more fat on your bones exactly you don't
know so you need a randomized control
trial to do that so what I what I argue
in the book is that well you know what
you see in terms of the health of people
living in that region of the world is
not because of the grains that they're
eating but in spite of the grains that
they're eating because when you actually
look at what greens are you know it's a
whole lot of starch wrapped in a little
bit of insoluble fiber and a tiny amount
of vitamins when building a you know a
healthy diet we want to really look for
things that are nutrient-dense that the
brain needs so well you know one of the
recommendations that I make to people
generally is to consume a huge salad a
fatty salad to every single day rather
than eating a bowl of brown rice which
is pretty nutritionally sparse dark
leafy greens contain a bevy of
micronutrients that the brain actually
needs to create energy and there's
really good research actually a study
was just published from Rush University
that found that people that consumed a
large bowl of dark leafy greens per day
have brains that look on scans eleven
years younger
Wow so yeah so I mean there's um
and you also realized with some of this
stuff that it you're not missing much
actually I mean just in this you know
week and whatever that I'm doing this
diet I got a poke a bowl yesterday and I
usually get brown rice on the bottom but
I got the leafy greens instead and I
actually in a way I enjoyed it more and
I felt kind of slimmer after because
yeah you're just taking in all that
right well you're gonna feel much better
I mean your body you know makes a lot of
effort to keep certain things within a
very narrow margin so for example your
your body temperature is one of those
things that your body works really hard
to keep with you know hovering at around
ninety eight point six degrees right the
same thing with your blood sugar at any
given time you've got you know one
teaspoon of circulating sugar in your
body and your pancreas works very hard
to keep your circulating blood sugar
that level the minute you eat a massive
bowl of brown rice or drink you know a
glass of orange juice which so many
Americans begin their day with which
contains about six to seven teaspoons of
pure sugar your that's like a deluge of
glucose being shuttled straight into
your blood that the vast majority of
people don't need where is that sugar
gonna go most likely it's gonna end up
on your hips and on your waist yeah
so basically soft drinks I mean I think
everyone sort of knows this and drinks
it despite the knowledge or at least the
knowledge is is readily accessible so
options are pretty much the worst thing
you can drink right I mean the amount of
sugar there is just anything horrible
yeah I mean the there's no you know
requirement for consuming added sugar a
lot of people actually feel that they
need sugar to fuel their brain because
of the boost and executive function that
they feel you know after consuming a
food that's sugary or you know a granola
bar or you know any carb rich food but
really so many people are hooked on
glucose as a fuel for the brain that in
reality what they're doing is they're
treating their withdrawal from sugar
from the previous meal and that's why
they feel boost so basically you have a
soda at lunch and then you're having
that crash like two hours later and
you're like oh I need that bar that has
exactly yeah and it tricks you tricks
but I mean it's it's there's a good
reason that you feel tricked and that
you feel like these foods are your
friends because you know when you're on
that sort of glucose rollercoaster
throughout the day you need those
constant pick-me-ups and that's the
problem so what I think you know is a
more sustainable way of having energy
cognitive resilience is to step off of
that that train the glucose train and
really reacquaint yourself with healthy
fats and foods that are much lower in
carbohydrates and much richer in the
nutrients that your brain actually needs
[Music]
you